[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Nick Nick mercs Colt Jeff is twitches
every man he's about lifting weights
shooting heads giving it 110 in game and
having a good time it takes just one
click and you're transported to Michigan
Nick's hometown to the land of the blue
and gold Michigan Wolverines Nick loves
so much
there you'll be exposed to that hyper
masculine attitude that winner-take-all
mentality and that I'll hunt you down
and lay in the kill competitive spirit
type of swagger after all you're part of
the em fam baby
[Music]
but this whole brand those plated
Spartan logos dabs and headshot
celebrations didn't get built on
fortnight Island not even close
Nick mercs hails from the old school of
eSports and to track his origin story
we'll have to take you all the way back
to the late 2000s where Nick first built
a name for himself as a Gears of War pro
what's going on I'm so pumped we got
Gears of War on the main stage with the
two most dominant Gears teams and Gears
of War history Infiniti taking on insane
I couldn't ask for a better better
championship coincidentally the
in-your-face style that Nick and bodies
on stream was a trademark of the
old-school Gears of War scene here stood
out from other eSports competitions at
the time year's tournaments were more
akin to a football game these guys
didn't just want to beat you they wanted
you to know how bad they beat you and
Gears of War you took no prisoners and
Nick was no exception
Nik also played professional halo while
coming up in the gaming sphere much like
a super streamer counterpart ninja and
very early on in his career he proved to
be someone who was lethal with a rifle
regardless of the game nick has always
been the aggressor in game he's not
going to play passively and let the game
come to him he's breaking down walls and
running right into the action guns
blazing across multiple FPS titles it's
this attitude if he became synonymous
with during his halo career he and ninja
even had a run-in while playing online
game battles they exchanged trash talk
and things got so heated that the beat
transcended the online world I told him
multiple times like bro you know you you
you cannot talk to me like that like you
you know you're you're gonna go to the
event that we're all going to in a month
now I'm telling you I shut your [ __ ]
mouth or I'm I sit you know and he did
not he would not stop talking man so we
basically long story short when they're
having this crazy game battles like feud
with them and I'm talking so much trash
to these guys I'm saying yo Nick's like
the worst player on the team all this
stuff and then and then they start like
threatening us online like we'll be
through you know beat the heck out of
you bro straight on get to the event him
Nick mercs and one of his buddies
teammates walked up to our entire squad
as we're walking the venue and like kind
of like push this like you want to go no
joke and we're like bro we were just big
till as game battles like but you can't
talk you kids off fresh on lined up back
it off in you could talk trash online
now back it off Nick used his
professional career as a jumping off
point to start a streaming career in
September of 2010
the first place huh right only get ahead
of myself for nothing I did just [ __ ]
one shot down I'm a god damn in his
early years Nick primarily streamed the
gaming world's most popular FPS titles
he played a lot of Call of Duty as you
might expect and even dipped into
outlast in 2014 when he started his
YouTube channel during that era Nick was
averaging around 900 concurrent viewers
on Twitch but his consistency and his
big personality combined with his legacy
in eSports played a key role in his
growth he was living the streaming grind
seeing small bursts of improvement
performing in game uploading to youtube
and trying to make it big and then
fortnight happened
[Music]
by now we don't need to tell you that
fortnight has revolutionized the twitch
experience its creative evocative casual
and competitive all at once it ignites
your imagination and brings the
broadcaster's who play it to life right
in front of you NIC joined 100 thieves
an up-and-coming organization run by
call of duty legend Matthew nadeshot
Hague in 2016 as a member of his content
team it brings me great pleasure to
announce that I will be inviting and
welcoming NIC mercs and his entire squad
to the hundred thieves team if you guys
don't know who they are then you will
find out very very quickly
the signing made sense 100 thieves was
eager to be on the cutting edge of new
games and Nick's personality driven
content blended well with their content
first approach and in classic Nick marks
fashion his elevation to becoming one of
the biggest names in the Fortnight world
came from his trademark aggression
our street Oh Nick first made a name for
himself by studying the squad's kill
record with a staggering 54 total
eliminations that moment onwards his
twitch traffic skyrocketed true to his
competitive roots Nick had no intention
of focusing strictly on content and was
able to blend his stream and competitive
hunger seamlessly even while fortnight's
eSports future was still completely
unknown Nick show he had what it took to
compete with the best during the very
first iteration of Kim stars fortnight
Friday grandis phase was it suffice Nick
and fellow streamer cypher dominated the
event and took home the $2,500 top prize
and make no mistake about it even though
fortnight's earliest events featured a
modest prize pool they were the best way
to build your name and Nick's thirst for
blood made him a hot topic of
conversation overnight now fortnight has
turned many streamers into overnight
celebrities but there's one very
specific reason why Nick mercs may be
the most unlikely of the bunch he plays
with the controller anybody anybody with
a brain man they know that controller
players in the grand scheme of things
are at a huge disadvantage it comes to
the game before nine minutes if you guys
think that because of a mice's and the
recent changes to the building if
anybody thinks that we're now at an
advantage
I don't know don't understand you guys
you know no matter what Epic Games does
to help players with controllers there's
just no way to sugarcoat it if you've
got a controller in your hands you're at
a disadvantage from the start in a
competitive landscape where the mouse
and keyboard reign supreme and that's
just part of what has made NICs
competitive career so captivating he's a
master with the controller he can't
build like cloaks or reverse 2k and he
doesn't try he plays his game
the bloodthirsty king up tilted towers
game
I like didn't hit him Nick made a name
for himself in the competitive community
from landing at tilted towers the game's
most hostile landmark every game and
playing aggressively and for kills he
may just be the most successful brute
force player on the planet and well it's
worked out pretty well for him
over the course of fortnight's brief
eSport history nick has racked up almost
one hundred and thirty thousand dollars
in prize winnings he competed and
continued to build his name throughout
Epic Games summer skirmish series where
he and cypher were a force to be
reckoned with town ninja sorrow and it
was during the skirmish series that he
first crossed paths with Aiden a high
school age controller player who played
just like Nick he dropped it tilted and
he slayed out and the two went at it
goes down Aiden says welcome to Tilton
and there it felt like every time there
was a competitive fortnight event Nick
and Aiden were having it out in Tilton
it became one of the biggest storylines
in the fort night world and bolstered
Aiden from a small time streamer to one
of the game's biggest names weird out at
his console players so to come in here
and look and compete and you know play
so high it's awesome and to meet Nick
it's it's awesome and having some good
controller players in here ended
storybook fashion once the dual portion
of the fall skirmish series ended the
too aggressive fraggers became one of
the most feared teams in the game huge
battle right now it's more gaussian st.
versus nick mercs innate and nick and
Aiden trailing getting some damage done
if they get these two they're in big
bonus territory painted matching this
look at what he's doing right absolutely
stopping he's got the high ground for
the moment the shop
[Applause]
through it all the battles were tilted
well shock them the growth of the EM fam
is entertaining duels with Tim the tap
man
if the fish is a betta fish so I figured
the best name for the fish would be Tim
his charity project ten hours and fifty
three thousand nine hundred dollars men
incredible I feel so great I feel so
great
and his intense will Cup qualifier bids
[Music]
he'll Nick mercs has grown into more
than a Fragger and an entertainer right
before our eyes he's built something new
something complete and untouchable
and in May of 2019 we saw the ugly side
of that Nick mercs announced his
departure from 100 thieves to wrap it up
I mean we went out there the plan was
for me to grow and in turn that would
grow 100 thieves right that was my role
you know and he made some promises to me
as a friend and how we were gonna do it
how he was going to take care of me
it just it just didn't end up happening
then in a world where twitch streamers
can be hoisted to a level of popularity
that Dwarfs even e-sports largest
endemic organizations big names like
Nick are invaluable but Nick didn't part
ways with nadeshot
on good terms I don't hate the guy you
know I definitely don't hate them but I
don't like them you know him and I are
not cool we're never gonna be cool I
don't want nothing to do with them I
never do business
we're him I'll never sit down at a table
with him ever again he didn't add much
detail but claimed that they were unkept
promises from nadeshot
and 100 thieves and true to form the la
lifestyle was not for him so he packed
up and went back to Michigan one of the
big things that I learned is I don't
like living out here I don't like people
like it's it might be for them a name
for me I want a porch I want a yard
I want snow I want it I want to I want
fall I want a spring I want my family
just a few days later Nick announced he
was joining faze clan whose relationship
with superstar fortnight player T foo
was in disarray there's a little more of
Nick and works a little more of that
East Coast grit in faze clan an org
synonymous with bragging and with their
roots in FPS eSports
we ultimately decided that instead of
being independent you know if there was
a team to play play for if there wasn't
a flag to ride it was face
[Music]
through Gears of War halo becoming a
streamer joining and leaving orgs and
building himself up as one of
fortnight's biggest personalities
there's always been something special
about Nick mercs something that makes
him unlike any other streamer something
that made you feel for him while we
watched as tilted towers was literally
blown to smithereens by a volcano
oh maybe more than anyone
he's a broadcaster that gives you a home
somewhere to hang out when you get home
from work to crack a beer or chat
weightlifting to laugh or to yell it's
easy to say that you're trying to build
a family within this weird internet
channel you call your own but to really
do it well that's something special his
channel is a place where tens of
thousands of people kick back with a
friend every day and land it tilted its
hostile and loud and tough and jokes and
it's always there for you when you need
it the M film thanks for watching if you
want more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up art Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
you